这条视频和大家讲怎么快速学习怎么快速度数
昨我妈很认诺读的方法都是错的
别看上红了,年学可能又不还你
这个方法可以用在什么地方
可以帮你上大学
说两个吃两个很重要的场景
首先拿我来说我是支持国主
我做的六年了,基本上是是够
基本几乎没断管,对吧
你要知道不断的输出
因为你的输入的能力更强
对不对
那么你的快速学习的能力很重要
比如说过两晚来,我可以学回来吗
短视频来都可以讀学短视频
我AID,我可以学AID
我在天呢,你们知道吗
这就你学东西比别人快
这个叫信息啥这个叫认知啥
你能干什么用,你们自己赶手
这第一个
第二件事情的话,就是
好多人刚才我说那肯定不知道怎么拍
不知道拍什么东西,第二个就是肯定是写了
东西自己写的东西,记不不搞的
今天跟我说,胡泽多,写东西我记不不搞的
我被不上词,我感不上六,是吧
我整个提起提起,多不行
就表情很深入
但我以后我拍东西的话,就是拿了有几百
不要说这个拍的短视频,就是我去做言计阳
上台之前,拿我的大概花一两分钟
想一下,我今天要讲什么
上台
这些三小时,没问题,加下来,怎么做到的
这个方法,就在这条视频里
我说一个场景,你们看一样和你们想不想像
就是我开一会儿说,我真的可能做笔记,花线,认真读,好好就提起
把数一枯,过上有段时间,分成那个数长的啥东西
大概讲了个什么东西
你也说不出太多的东西来,对不对
原因是什么
这背后是有原因的,首先给大家讲
就是我们大脑的学习,他有一种
他举个例子就是他跟那一村很小
我们有那一村来举例子,那一村很小
他能够放多少呢,四到七个只只够
差不多就到七个只够只够,再多就不行了
我们在学东西的时候,要牵过两年,是第一年事,只是我要聆业这个概念
这个概念什么意思,那个公司到底什么意思
我叫聆业了,同时你要和其他的知识见面点击
一多就完了,所以为什么学东西的时候一定要吃会化,化出来
因为你化了过程中,把一些东西放到指面上,然后拿着指专注那个部分
但是,老子是认知负责的这个问题
但是我们很觉得,概念什么的价格
我记不住,肯定是我学的不认真
我要化更多的时间去去读,认真的更多的时间就理解
我就化现我去寄笔寄,对不对
其实你搞错了
你要倒回来,你倒回来讲,不是说从头到尾一点一年多,而是什么呢?
而是,只记,框架
就是你学一个东西的时候,脑子之前有个框架
然后你学的这个细节,你真,框架的脑子要是要有框架的,要秀成读吗?
你有一个股价才能
去提怎么做呢?
我给大家介绍几个方法,首先第一个就是你读一本书的时候,就是读一本书的时候
不要,一定要不要从头读到尾
不要,不要,千万不要,那么好的书都不要
怎一怎么办呢?就是首先第一件事情,先找出这本书的关键概念
你翻来说,好书,好书,像我这种好书
标题,目录的一点基本上就会说明关键跟你讲的,大家看见的人
看一些每一张大张的手张,然后黑影子,不可能,一个特别重要的概念
好,然后也不放黑影子里,放标题里,放那个技术卡拉里,不可能
如果是这样的话,这个写书的事,大概五,明白吗?
好,基本上看书,不要太多,就是抽取十个左右的关键概念够了,十个左右关键概念,可以了
不一定完全对,但是大家看一样,放了标题了,重复出现的,大概你就得很重要的,千元,大概早点,好了,可以了
这是第一步,找到十个关键概念
第二件事情,做针对的是个关键概念,有点得见层次,什么意思呢?
见三层,哪个关键概念是最重要的,是负层
有哪些关键概念是围绕的这个层的,是围绕的这个层的,叫此层
还有的话呢,是孙子层的一味,大概哪里有这么一个骨家,你也不一定完全对,但是你大概倒了一些话,这个东西
好了,这是这二件事了
刚,第一件事是个关键概念,第二件就是三层,他们之间是一个什么样的成理
第三个话都好了,你可以开始读了
无某一段数,读完了以后,这个是关键的那个部分
一条线穿起来,这个骨家的那儿,然后我那个是关的那儿,看完了,然后再看下一个,再关的
对不对,这还有什么好说呢,就是我们讲的认识负责,我刚才说了
大脑,其实能放的东西很少,但是脑里要做两件事,一个事是干嘛的,一个事就是
我要理解这个东西,第二个部分是什么的,我要和他见的点击,在谁上,你开始把骨家换出来的
但那个骨家中间可能会改啊,但是你先换出来的,然后你会发现这个时候你就泄在了,你只需要掉,做的东西只关注那个支地就可以了
关注完以后,关上
第二个事情,跟大家讲,再好的事,再好的论人,我告诉你,关键概念不会太多
二八元多,我这个时候,好说啊,右边就那些养活的事,对吧,这个时候绝对是好说,对啊,我告诉你,它的关键概念不会超过失了,关键概念不会超过失了
这样的好说,对吧,所以,所以,其实十分二八元责的,就是百分之二十的关键,关键概念称值得一本书一个多人百分之百事的核心店
对吧,这样的话你会发现少订的事吗,好了,这个时候你有过一下,但你一定要明白有骨鸡在去天内容,你脑子就很清晰的,但是你要明白啊,千万
不要因为有个骨鸡之后你就觉得,我就掌握了,不是啊,骨鸡,它只是一个地图,它不是整个的地方,这个大家能体会吧,好
然后你会发现我拍的个点,你们今天就会是,比如说,你们今天就可以答应的时候,你可以试试
你可以拿一片长文张,好就想看了一声没看得很长,你可以试试,我已经讲我拍视频了,我拍视频不会像你们一样,哎呀,我要记整个版本的才是这个地方怎么怎么样,我按脑了就是几个关键概念,就是有关键概念
我的关键概念里面,哦,它能成理什么样,好的可以了,那你不能一样,对,你们今天就找一片没看我的文张,甚至你就干脆你拿的时候视频,你去拔一拔,哦,这条视频里的关键概念,是几个,他们这个关键是什么样子,然后传终,一条线,尝试一下